what do we have here we have two
new colors we've got the new mystic red
and mystic white
the samsung galaxy z flip was
is my favorite phone of 2020. that's not
to say that i didn't love the fold too
but there's just something about
this phone that just felt incredible
like being able to flip that thing open
it was just really cool look at that box
oh so cool
i was actually just reminiscing about
when i got the original
z flip we went to the mall we went all
the way to glendale which is not
actually that far but when you live in
the west side of los angeles
you might as well just charter a
helicopter at that point but i went and
met john at the samsung store because he
had ordered two of these
so then i went and bought it off of him
and went to the mall that was a really
fun video
that was right before lockdown oh
i'm so excited to see this i'm so
excited
it's so freaking fresh
i don't even know what to say
this is like the perfect color it's like
a matte
finish as well look at that
holy crap this is beautiful
[Music]
oh my goodness i'm smudging it up
already
oh my god are you look at this
like just beautiful
iridescent mystic white
[Music]
see what else is in here charger
cable i mean this is gonna kind of be a
really quick video because you've
already seen reviews
of both of these phones on mine and
everyone's channels
there's really not much else to say
about it do you want to get a closer
look yeah get in there
[Music]
even the little hinge has sort of an
iridescent color yes a little shade of
purple
and like a pink just enough to give it
sort of that opal kind of iridescent
look
[Music]
so now let's check out the red note 25g
oh no take a look at this
wow i'm not a huge fan of the color red
but when it is on like these types of
devices with sort of this kind of matte
frosted glass back just really gives
these phones like a whole other look it
gives it sort of a dimensional type look
look at that
wow get closer get closer get closer
[Music]
let's look at both of these together
yeah those look great so i know this is
kind of a short video but i really
wanted to show these
to you guys because i really do love
when they kind of bring out different
colors and different variations
and i feel like the more videos and more
content that you see these in actual
people's hands the better that you're
able to judge what the color would
actually look like when you get it in
person so
this is it this is what they look like
and i really really
i really love this red i'm wondering
from you guys though what is your
favorite phone that was released in 2020
also what is your favorite color phone
that was released in 2020
even if that's not your favorite phone
from this year you can still say that
you like the color
also what do you guys think about these
do you like the red do you like the
mystic whites
because clearly we all know i'm obsessed
i'll see you guys in my next video bye
you